[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist I got
with me my co-host Czech nice chck hey
Neil what's happening today I think is
one of the hottest topics in all of
science we want to figure out what dark
energy is who made it where's it coming
from where's it going and will we all
die will we all
die once once we find out what it is
yeah the universe can't tell us unless
it kills US unless it kills US unless it
kills us right we've got with us for
this episode my friend and colleague
Jason rhods Jason welcome to Star talk
thank you for inviting me I'm really
looking forward to talking about Dark
Energy with all of you today yeah yeah
so you've you you you Hil from the jet
propulsion Labs we all know that's in
Pasadena California it's a branch one of
10 branches of NASA and jpl's affiliated
with Cal Tech and so that makes sure you
all are doing the right things all right
Y no slouching that's right we we have
two bosses here Caltech and JPL so or
sorry Caltech and NASA and NASA and NASA
so and and JPL right you got NASA
headquarters JPL headquarters and okay
so no no no no slouching there I so you
your research interest what I like about
you for this conversation is you not
only have deep interest in dark energy
which we'll get to in a minute which we
all do but you also you're not just
talking about it you're actually trying
to solve the problem using experiments
using telescopes detectors balloons and
I want to get into how all that works
How could a balloon launched from Earth
tell you anything about dark energy in
the universe so unless it's a Chinese
spy balloon oh
those hey those balloons are able to
tell you a great
de all right so first tell me just
remind us all what dark energy is and
how you got into it well uh dark energy
is really the name we give to our
ignorance of what's causing the universe
to expand faster and faster over time
and about 25 years ago uh two groups of
scientists were trying to understand how
fast the universe was expanding and how
how that uh expansion was slowing down
due to gravity and so they were doing
these experiments
and they almost simultaneously came up
with the same result which was very
surprising it was not slowing down due
to gravity but instead that expansion
was speeding up as if something was
pushing the universe apart and they gave
the name of whatever that is uh dark
energy and we are still 25 years later
trying to figure out what that dark
energy is where it comes from and what
it's going to do to the universe in the
future and right now we think dark
energy is the dominant component of the
universe IE and is only going to become
more dominant over time in the future so
this is an invasion what you're saying
we're actually being taken over we're
being yeah we're being taken over by
this Force we really are and if you look
back uh deep into the universe's history
10 billion years ago Dark Energy was a
very subdominant small component of the
universe uh now it's the dominant
component of the universe and as I said
10 billion years or more from now it's
going to be even more dominant where the
universe is completely dominated by this
dark energy so it really is an invasion
well so how do you get if we're if the
universe is expanding and Getting
Thinner how do you get more of something
that is a a really interesting question
for us to ask so one of the theories of
dark energy is maybe it's a prop
property of SpaceTime itself and that is
when there's more SpaceTime there's more
dark energy and as there's more Dark
Energy it's causing SpaceTime to to uh
expand faster and faster making more and
more Dark Energy in this sort of runaway
effect and for some so it's it's
self-propagating is that a little bit
like that and for some physicists uh
they don't like this because it really
sounds like a a violation of the
conservation of energy we're getting
more Dark Energy uh over time so if we
think of dark energy as as energy in the
classical Newtonian physics sense uh
we're really not conserving energy in
Universe which is a very distasteful
concept to some physicists uh on the
other hand the equations we're using to
describe Dark Energy uh are just
equations that have been around for a
hundred years come from Einstein and
they seem to fit the universe so the
universe is telling us something very
profound here it's telling us something
profound but it's also contradicting
something profound at this at the same
time it's it's very much like being in
in a weird relationship you know where
you don't know what to do I would say
you're allowed to contradict something
profound with something equally as
profound and then you know put it in the
octagon and let it sort itself out you
know nice I like that so two postulates
enter one
postulate so so if you universe is
expanding then the gravity is
thinning so the dark energy is becoming
ever more powerful
regardless and relative to gravity it's
getting that much more powerful so
gravity doesn't stand a chance going
forward that's right we are seeing a
universe that's increasingly dominated
by this uh Dark Energy so Jason that the
original results from 25 years ago which
if I remember correctly got the Nobel
Prize the discovery of dark energy uh
they use like Supernova exploding like
out to the edges of the universe and you
get a distance from that get a distance
from some Hubble laws and so is are
there other ways to verify that to know
that what we're thinking is really that
that these me these other measurements
are really true so uh the original
Supernova experiments that they did in
the 1990 to discover the dark energy we
looking at Supernova out to a z or red
shift of about one and one of the things
we'd like to do is we'd like to push
that uh back push those measurements
back further to a red shift of about two
and for that we're going to use the
Nancy Grace Roman Space Telescope which
NASA will launch in
2027 whoa wait you mean the so so the
the crime lady from HLN actually was an
astronomer as well no in fact Nancy
Grace Roman was NASA's first Chief
astronomer soon after NASA was uh uh
formed in
1958 and she was a champion of space
telescopes and in fact she was was
called the mother of the large Space
Telescope and the large Space Telescope
when it was launched had a different
name and that was the Hubble Space
Telescope so she was really one of the
chief people pushing uh to build the
hubbles Space Telescope which of course
has transformed our views of of the
universe and astrophysics in in so many
ways look at that behind the scenes a
great woman and of course out front some
dude taking all the credit you talking
Mr Hubble I mean I don't get me wrong I
understand Hubble was a incredible
scientist and he deserved to have his
name on the telescope but who knew that
behind that whole project there was a
woman pushing the entire thing that's
amazing so Jason I know that Lyman
Spitzer wrote a very early research
paper after the second world war
realizing that if V2 Rockets can leave
the atmosphere and do harm uh they can
also launch something into orbit like a
telescope and he knew the value of
telescopes above Earth atmosphere for
this purpose but uh he wasn't active
with NASA right somebody at Nasa inside
has to make this happen as a
goal yeah sure and Lyman Spitzer was a
huge voice in the science Community uh
making space telescopes happen at the
same time that people like Nancy Grace
Roman at Nasa were making them happen
and of course Lyman Spitzer had a a
fantastic infrared Space Telescope named
after him and so 2027 Nancy Grace Roman
is finally going to get her du with the
Space Telescope named after her there
you go look at that the women first in
last out look at that God so
predictable so what do these telescopes
going to do uh are they still going to
look at Supernova but just farther away
so one of the things Roman will do is
look at Supernova but Roman is going to
join a telescope already in space called
The ukl Space Telescope and use a couple
of other techniques to uh look for dark
energy and those techniques include weak
gravitational lensing where we look at
small distortions in the measured shapes
of background galaxies to measure the
Dark Matter between us and those
galaxies and also a technique called
barion acoustic oscillations which is a
way of talking about uh the clustering
of galaxies how close galaxies are to
each other wait so the you're talking
about dark matter there right not dark
energy that's right right did I hear you
right you did and so one of the things
that we know is that dark matter which
is another mysterious component of the
universe interacts with gravity so over
time Dark Matter becomes more clustered
due to gravity gravity tends to pull
things together but at the same time the
dark matter is pushed apart by the dark
energy so by looking at how dark matter
clusters and changes over time we're
learning about not just the Dark Matter
itself but the interplay between gravity
and dark energy and so that's how we
learn about uh dark energy by studying
Dark
Matter okay so you so you know what to
expect from dark matter and if it
doesn't live up to those expectations
something else is meddling within it and
you can track that over dis over time
that's right okay that's
interesting all right now what's this
about
balloons well the reason we want to go
to space with a telescope is we want to
get above the Earth's atmosphere the
Earth's atmosphere causes uh things to
twinkle causes stars to twinkle you know
I have a two-year-old daughter and she
started to sing Twinkle Twinkle Little
Star and I want to stop her and say no
no it's not the star that's twinkling
that's actually the atmosphere um I I I
hold myself back but we want to get
above yeah fun
yeah sweetie it's it should you should
be singing Twinkle Twinkle refracting
atmosphere okay that's right I I'll
correct her when she's three um but
worst worst dad ever
right the the uh atmosphere also absorbs
a lot of wavelengths of light so we want
to get above the atmosphere but a rocket
launch uh is expensive and it takes a
lot of time to develop a space mission
that's going to go into space and you
can't uh tweak it so one of the things
that NASA and other space agencies do is
they put uh telescopes hanging from
balloons and these are huge balloons the
size of a football stadium uh that are
filled with helium and they take these
uh telescopes to the uh edge of the
atmosphere so that they're above most of
the atmosphere and then we can do uh
days or uh even weeks of observations
above most of the atmosphere and so we
just did that uh earlier this spring
with um a balloon called superbit which
circumnavigated the Earth about five
times from a launch in New Zealand uh
it's just the winds that take it around
the earth and all that time we were
making observations of clusters of
galaxies trying to understand the dark
matter in those Galaxy clusters China
didn't shoot it
down no in fact NASA brought it down on
purpose uh over land because most of the
earth is ocean and we wanted to recover
the telescope and the hard drives so
NASA eventually said right we're going
to bring it down where we can send a
team to get the hard drives because if
they fall into the ocean uh we're not
getting those back well I mean listen
why why not uh you're you're sending up
a balloon you want to tell me you can't
attach a little raft to it or some some
swimmies some swimmies so that you can
so it will float you can get the hard
drives I mean even even if something
were to happen by accident and listen by
no means am I uh uh denigrating the
Great efforts that you guys do but I'm
just saying as a person who's been to a
pool that uh if you put some swimmies on
your telescope you might be able to
recover it in case of emergency a
minimum a pool noodle you know
exactly that that wouldn't be a that
would have been a good idea yeah but but
we did come up with what I thought was a
crazy idea about 10 years ago we said
you know hard drives are cheap compared
to everything else Let's uh eject some
drives from this balloon and bring him
down on a glider or a parachute uh
during the mission and so we had a crazy
idea and we we pursued it a bit and in
fact we actually employed that on this
super bit Mission and we dropped some
hard drives from way up in the
atmosphere and then um had them fall to
the Earth and then we can go recover it
it turns out we didn't need to do that
because we used uh satellite downlink of
the data and we were getting it all down
but we didn't know how well that was was
going to work uh so we had this backup
of just dropping the hard drives out of
the sky and finding them where they fell
to the ground that makes sense in this
age of 5G you can just take the almost
in real time take the information as
you're collecting so yeah back in my day
back back in my day we we would we would
speak of bandwidth uh we would compare
bandwidth to the bandwidth of FedEx
right you just take a tape hand it to
FedEx and they delivered across the
country faster than the Uplink would
allow you to transmit the data so I
remember when we used to put satellites
in space using a giant rubber band it
was like a slingshot it was made by
Acme I'd like these other methods to try
to think about Dark Energy so all you're
doing though is making more measurements
of what we know is there but you're not
really telling us what it's made of well
the way I like to describe describe it
is there's lots of theories for what
Dark Energy might be a new force a
property of SpaceTime uh um some
mysterious particle lots of different
theories and the theorists have really
had a field day and these theories uh
all produce uh results in the or would
produce results in the real world that
are slightly different uh and especially
different with these different
measurements Supernova the barion
oscillations and the weak lensing and so
what we're trying to do is gather all
the data to rule pull out huge classes
of theories and say it wasn't that it
wasn't that and it's sort of a Last Man
Standing thing where we say okay it's
this one there might be just one left
that you can't rule out and so maybe
that's it I I get you okay all right
cool interesting right Chuck let's go to
Q&A here we got some you want to go to
Q&A let's got got some patreon members
here uh who we go who support us at the
level of $5 a month that's all less than
a cup of that's Starbucks Coffee you get
to ask questions and thank you all for
supporting us on patreon and uh this is
Calvin wait and Calvin says hello Jason
Lord nice and the longtime reigning king
of Star Talk and the cosmos Neil degrass
because they think that's going to get
their questions answered more but
apparently it is they're right because
I'm reading it
clearly sucking up
words all right uh no this is why I'm
reading it because he says I am 13 years
old and I recently became a patreon
member this is a 13-year old kid who is
taking his paper rout money and giving
it to Star talk so that he can ask
questions so the rest of you have no
excuse at all okay well he doesn't know
what the term paper out even means so no
he doesn't I know I know right uh I'm
dating myself cuz I had a paper uh I am
currently on a trip in in to toint
Alaska and I send you my regards with
this question due to the theory that the
space and time places flip in a black
hole wa wait that's TNA tala tala is
that how you say that does it spell that
way it's just EXA yeah yeah my wife is
from Alaska and that's a that's a I said
tala but it's t yeah yeah okay TNA due
to the theory that space and time flip
places in a black hole if said black
hole is comprised of Dark Matter could
we harness this dark matter or energy to
travel through time and create wormholes
to distant galaxies I've been a fan for
a very long time and I'm so excited to
hear the answer
oh yeah Jason un what do you got for
that well I'm gonna say unfortunately uh
Calvin I think I had the name right
unfortunately once uh matter whether
it's dark matter or uh normal matter
falls into a black hole it's really gone
to us and we have no way to access it
and so uh a black hole could have normal
matter in it it could have uh um dark
matter in it but uh that matter is gone
and we don't have a way to access or
harness the matter inside the black hole
do you think the black hole cared
whether it ate matter or dark matter it
just ate I think it was indifferent it's
gonna grow either
way it doesn't discriminate it doesn't
care now what's goingon to be fun is if
Calvin
actually invents this device in his
basement and then comes back say see I
was right all along see that's what's
going to happen here you know you know
that that that sort of reminds me um
Neil that a lot of people think
scientists never want to be wrong but I
would be thrilled if Calvin invented
that and and in general scientists are
thrilled when their experiment shows
something that makes them go huh that's
not what I was expecting and so that's
what happened with dark energy 25 years
ago we we as a a community said that is
not what we expecting and it's really
exciting to be alive in a time where we
find something completely unexpected
this was Isaac asimov's edict he said
the the the the Clarion call of the
scientist is not Eureka it's h that's
that's
funny you see some result he said I I
what is I don't know what this is that's
the discovery it's not Eureka it can be
Eureka but mostly it's not right right
all right Chuck give me more all right
this is Roland p and Roland P says hello
Dr Tyson Lord nice and Dr rhs my name is
rollan and I'm writing from cologne
German Ley sorry Chuck my na my last
name is unpronouncable to
you you don't even give me a chance to
butcher your name man you don't even
give me a chance to butcher abbreviated
with a p right he just went with the p
you know what I
mean my question about my question is
about the uid mission when they say the
probe will generate a 3D map of the
universe how do you cope with the fact
that most of this map is
outdated the Stars you are seeing might
not be there anymore the Galaxies have
moved they've merged Etc during the
billions of years the light took to
reach us what you're looking that is a
ghostly
image oh look at that Gauntlet thrown
down there Jason what's going on that is
a very interesting question and the
answer is we don't want to know
necessarily what those uh parts of the
universe look like today because we
assume that they look very similar to
the parts of the universe close to us
that we can already see we want to see
what the parts of the universe looked
like in the past and that's why we're
looking further and further out we're
using infrared light to look closer to
the beginning of the universe because we
want to see how the universe has evolved
so we don't want a static picture of the
universe today we want to measure this
three-dimensional map uh where looking
further away in that third dimension is
also looking further back in time so we
want to look at the time evolution of
the universe because that's what's
driven by this interplay between dark
energy and gravity so that uh what what
Roland has brought up is not so much a
um a problem with uid it's what uclid is
designed to measure uid is a European
Space Agency correct yes uclid is a
European Space Agency mission that
launched uh July 1st 2023 I'm wearing my
uclid shirt because I'm the US science
lead for uid NASA provided some uh great
infrared detector technology to uid and
we have over a 100 NASA funded us
scientists working on on uclid with our
European counterparts so when these
agencies uh come together and
collaborate but yet you're still working
independently is there any competition
or jealousy when somebody comes up with
something great and the other part did
not tell the truth
please scientists are still human so we
can be jealous when somebody else has a
a good idea or a a great uh uh Mission
from another uh agency or another uh
country but what we're seeing
increasingly is scientists from
different uh countries and agencies from
different countries working together
because the telescopes and the projects
are becoming uh more complex and more
interconnected and so we have a
telescope like uclid uh that will work
in certain ways and it's going to be
very complimentary to NASA's Roman
telescope which the European Space
Agency is participating in just like
NASA participated in ID so we're working
together to build all of these
telescopes on the ground in space and
we're going to use the data from all of
these telescopes as a science Community
together to get the best constraints on
dark matter and dark energy and the
properties of the Universe I so I like
the idea that you're saying we're
looking back in time on purpose and the
fact that galaxies might have collided
or Stars won't be there by today you
don't care you care that they were there
back when we saw them so that's an
important distinction to make here there
all right check it's very cool very cool
let's go to Fabiola Horath and Fabiola
says my dear Dr Tyson Dr rhods and sweet
Lord nice Fabiola here from Hungary we
are international for sure today man uh
in my opinion uclid might be one of the
most exciting research tools ever built
can't wait for the results I wonder if
it will be able to shed light on what
the great
attractor might be or debunk its EX
existence once and for all thank you all
I will always keep looking up and please
tell me your thoughts on the great
attractor so the great attractor is a um
a a group of of galaxies and the
associated uh Dark Matter associated
with those galaxies that's relatively
nearby uh in the universe um and is
attracting other galaxies towards it
through its gravity and so uid will be
able to produce uh not just a map of the
Dark Matter there but a map of the Dark
Matter over fully a third of the sky so
onethird of the sky um and that's the
the best third of the sky in the sense
that it's the darkest uh and furthest
away from our Milky Way which is
littered with stars which block our view
of the distant galaxies so uclid will
produce a huge Dark Matter map uh that
not only can tell us about this great
attractor but other many other thousands
of other dark matter conglomerations or
Galaxy clusters out there in the
universe much further away than just the
the local universe that we've been
studying for the last hundred years but
what's what's been doing the attracting
in the great attractor is it related to
the work you're doing well we think it's
um galaxies and the the Dark Matter
associated with those galaxies so it's
just a a big conglomeration of mass as
they Co coales and all this m comes
together it just creates more of an
attraction is that the deal or is it
something like the great garbage patch
where there's a natural flow to a a
particular point something like a like
you know or or or something even more
like the pooling of a lrange point do
you guys or do you know I'm I mean I'm
just at this point I'm just throwing out
a bunch of stuff
well in fact this is very related to one
of the ways that uid and and in a few
years Roman will probe Dark Energy it's
going to we're going to use a technique
called red shift space distortions and
what that is is it's us looking at
galaxies in red shift so we're going to
see where they are in three-dimensional
space that red shift tells us the
distance but there's some distortions
there uh in those measurements because
there's a local movement of the galaxies
as they're attracted to uh big
conglomerations of uh dark matter and so
we're looking at those sort of very
minute local distortions in how the
galaxies are moving and encoded in the
Motions of the galaxies is a lot of
information about the dark matter and as
we've talked about that information
about the dark matter is going to tell
us about the properties of dark energy
uh in the universe so the so the
movement of the
galaxies separate from the expansion of
the universe is they they are your
probes for the structure of where all
the gravity is locally local to that
region is that a fair way to
characterize that's exactly right yes we
want to okay all right probe that local
structure yeah yeah all right all right
Chuck keep it going time for a few more
okay so this is Ed ianowski who says
greetings from Portland Oregon in
considering things like dark matter and
dark energy it seems we don't use aam's
razor that much why do we assume that
dark matter is matter at all or that
dark energy is indeed energy what about
the nature of space itself we know space
can warp stretch expand just because
regular matter warps space do we have to
assume that the warping associated with
this dark matter is also caused by some
sort of matter that we call dark
couldn't it just be a part of the nature
of space itself what is space and why
does it produce a vacuum energy virtual
particles and the
such okay all right I that's a lot okay
wow that was a lot wasn't it I'm G
address the Dark Matter part first so
you know Dark Matter was first theorized
uh you know close to a 100 years ago and
the real um the first real uh strong
evidence for Dark Matter was found um
say in the 1970s and and before that by
a a pioneering astronomer named ver
Ruben who who looked at uh the the
rotations of galaxies and said these
galaxies are rotating faster than they
should be if if the um if the uh
galaxies are made up of just stars and
dust so there must be something else in
there and so this was the first real
evidence uh for dark matter and at the
time uh Dark Matter was just the name
given to whatever was causing this uh uh
rotating galaxies to be rotating faster
than we thought they should be however
over the course of the last half century
we've had
increasingly uh an increasing number of
different observations across all areas
of astrophysics which have told us that
this dark matter is there it's some sort
of particle and it is a mass uh just
like normal matter but it just only
interacts gravitationally and so the
dark matter has gone from being sort of
the way we explain some observations to
being something predictive
that is I am able to now say okay I
think this is the properties of dark
matter so I should go out and I should
measure something and indeed I I confirm
that yes there probably is this dark
matter out there wait wait you you don't
have a dark matter particle yet though
we we do not what are you saying well so
there's two ways to look for dark matter
there's the astrophysical way why'd you
say that up front Okay you say well we
don't have any kind of dark matter
particle but we still want to think it's
matter that that's what you just said
yeah okay okay so what gives you the
confidence that dark matter is made of
matter if we don't have a dark matter
particle yet so we see uh a lot of
clustering of dark matter um at
different levels in the universe so
there's what we call a hierarchical
clustering clustering of dark matter
that we can uh we can measure and if
it's a particle that's the exact type of
uh clustering we would see so and we see
this
astrophysically um so lots of groups on
the ground are trying to detect the Dark
Matter particle and they so far have
only come up with what we call null
detections okay wow all right that is so
cool okay so null detections is they
think it's a particular kind of particle
they set up a an experiment and they
should see that it's not then they think
is it a different kind of other particle
you set up a way to detect it and it's
not so these are all the null detections
so once again maybe some other particle
will will be the last the last man
standing that's right that's right right
right okay so you guys I mean that's a
long process you just have to keep
ruling things out like you're striking
the list half of science is ruling stuff
out half it's just ruling it out a lot
of
Science and okay now what about the guy
kept going though he he he didn't stop
there where else did he go well he he
asked about dark energy and indeed Dark
Energy may be simply a process or a or a
um a property a property of SpaceTime
that's right a property of SpaceTime
right and uh I don't know that dark
energy was the best name for our
ignorance of what's causing the
accelerating expansion of the universe
but I wasn't the one that was asked to
name it uh so that's the name somebody
uh came up with uh I think it was
actually a US astrophysicist named Mike
Turner who came up with the name Dark
Energy um and that's that's the name
that's stuck but it's not an energy in
the classical uh physics sense of an
energy that that we think about it's
perhaps some property of the universe so
we don't really know and that's where we
really are uh just designing these
experiments to rule out big classes of
of
theories I I would add that the Dark
Matter could be literally and accurately
named dark gravity but no no no one
picked up on that and so because that's
what it is right it's it's gra it's
gravity and we don't know where it came
from so it's dark gravity and people
just assuming that matter you need
matter to have gravity and I thought
that was overstepping given our state of
ignorance at the time that that's uh
that's very possible and you know I
think even Dark Matter isn't the best
name because you can see the screen
behind me is is mostly dark because it's
absorbing the light well dark matter
doesn't absorb or give off light so it
could be more accurately now called
clear matter because the light passes
right through it uh but it's the the
path of the light is distorted by the
gravity but the light passes right
through it so that it doesn't interact
with the light at all uh no it doesn't
interact with the light at all it only
bends SpaceTime the Dark Matter bends
SpaceTime so the path of the light is is
curved I gotta but see that happens
anyway to
I light surface yeah you get that for
free get that for free so but you Chuck
your hair is dark because it's absorbing
light hitting it and not reflecting it
back to me it's interacting with the
light yes I thank you for
noticing I app I appreciate
that give me a couple more bring them on
all right let's uh let's go with Kevin
Curry and Kevin says hello this is Kevin
Curry from Sparks Nevada my question is
about gravity I understand that gravity
Moves In Waves and propagates at the
speed of light however do masses with
high gravitational fields affect the
waves from other masses if so is it
possible to tell them apart if not how
can we know the Gravity from one Mass
actually came from the specific mass and
was not modified by another Mass between
us and the original masses in short is
gravity affected by gravity oh
I I I like this question because it uh
allows me to mention a new way of
measuring the universe that's become uh
increasingly uh popular and increasingly
possible over the last uh decade and
that's by measuring gravitational waves
these are ripples in in SpaceTime caused
by Massive particles uh or or not
particles but massive objects like black
holes uh orbiting each other or neutron
stars orbiting each other and they give
off these gravitational waves and we can
see those gravitational waves interact
uh with each other and they uh interact
with our very sensitive detectors here
on Earth that are looking for very very
minute uh uh changes in the uh path of a
wavelength of of laser light that are
caused by these ripples in SpaceTime and
that's only in the last uh decade or
even less than a decade that we've been
able to measure these and it's an
entirely new
window on the universe uh previously we
had used light whether that's uh light
that we can see or radio waves or x-rays
but always electromagnetic radiation and
now we're building telescopes and using
different techniques to study these
gravitational waves which are telling us
about some of the same phenomena but in
a very different way so it's a really
exciting time to be an
astrophysicist well if two of them
intersect do they resonate in some way
do they cancel each other out outout two
gravitational waves moving through space
from two different Origins I think they
can they can interact if you imagine uh
ripples on a pond uh if you throw a
pebble in and you throw another Pebble
in you can get the interaction and I
think it's very similar for for
gravitational waves you can get that uh
interaction and that's uh likely
something that we'll be able to uh you
know measure in the future as we get
ever more um accurate uh detectors and
in fact there's a mission that uh the
European Space Agency is going to build
in in hopefully the
2030s um uh and NASA will participate
called Lisa where they're going to put
these uh lasers in space to measure
gravitational waves in
Space over a much bigger Baseline than
just two locations on Earth's surface
that's right right so you can get to see
that okay all right I'm loving it all
right check deep question these people
are on point today I have to by the way
our 13-year-old has already created the
Wormhole I just got report yes exactly
congratulations uh this is Thomas
Cochran who says greetings from Kansas
City Missouri I'm curious how uclid will
go about exploring the mystery of dark
energy with instruments that are tuned
to collect data in the visible and near
infrared Spectrum any speculation on how
we can circumnavigate the issue of
collecting data on something that
doesn't interact with our universe in
this typical way thank thank you for
making us all
smarter right so we just learned that it
doesn't interact with light so he's
asking if it doesn't interact with light
how are you using light to actually
measure something so we're measuring the
properties of galaxies and those
properties are the shapes the distances
and the Motions of the galaxies and
encoded in the shapes distances and
motions of galaxies is a lot of
information about dark matter and dark
energy we can't measure dark matter and
dark energy directly but we measure
those properties of the galaxies using
visible and infrared light and then we
use the techniques that I talked about
earlier the gravitational lensing the
bury on acoustic oscillations the red
shift space distortions uh by measuring
those galaxies to discern the properties
of dark matter and dark energy
everything's a bank shot everything
you're doing is a bank shot that's
basically what you're saying it's like
yeah we don't try to sink the basket we
go off the backboard right that's the
deal but whatever way you can right I
mean that's
right yeah I'll tell you just in a side
to this trck you know the electron which
we all talk about and we you know what
the charge is and we don't know how big
it is oh wow we've never measured the
size of an electron
ever as for as far as we know it's
infinitesimally small so what does it
even mean to talk about an electron as
though it's an actual particle when in
fact what we really mean is is whatever
it is it has these properties that we've
measured for it and it's the properties
that interact with everything else we
care about so if we don't know how big
it is so so there's been no actual
citing of an electron basically but you
can site the effects of an electron but
not the electron itself right right so
that's all Jason is saying I think Jason
is that the better the more precisely
you know the galaxies the better you are
able to know what effect the Dark Matter
dark energy has on the Galaxy because
that's otherwise you're not catching it
in the open field right that's that's
right with one subtlety in that these
effects uh of dark matter and dark
energy uh are very subtle and so we want
to measure not just a very precise
measurement of a Galaxy what we're going
to do with uclid is we're going to
measure shapes of over a billion
galaxies and to do a statistical study
uh and so it's really uh these new
telescopes uid then Roman in a few years
are going to provide huge amounts of
data huge amounts of measurements on
Galaxies that allow us to uh discern the
properties of dark matter and dark
energy through statistical studies so
our measurement of any one Galax yet if
a billion galy youve got AI helping you
in there somewhere we we we have to have
ai helping us because we can't we don't
have enough grad students to look at
each Galaxy individually right over time
yes
yeah you need something that can look at
millions of them all at once and say
that's not necessary or we don't have to
look at that or those are all the same
here are the anomalies that makes sense
that's super cool man
damn you guys have such a cool job it's
amazing what we got time for one last
question I think chck this is Gavin
Bamber babber and says hello from North
Vancouver
where where it doesn't matter that I
have energy what okay okay but yeah he's
um I think that was a joke he says why
is it called the euklid mission and how
does that how does any of this pertain
to Geometry okay he's going he's going
very literal with the
ukan calling yes calling it out so when
we were looking for a name for this
Mission uh we thought about what are we
measuring and when you measure the uh
expansion history uh of the universe uh
one way that scientists describe that
they say you're measuring the geometry
of the universe what the universe looks
like and who is more associated with uh
geometry than the the father of geometry
uh uid who wrote a textbook on Geometry
um you know 2,000 years ago uh that was
still in use up to a couple hundred
years ago so this was an amazing uh
scientist uh who who really founded the
field of geometry and so we were trying
to measure the geometry of the whole
universe so it seemed an apt person to
name this mission after now I would add
however I would add Ju Just to be just
to be snarky but I agree with everything
you said of course but to be snarky uh
when Einstein showed that matter and
energy distort the fabric of space and
time ukian geometry was no longer
ukian it was non ukian geometry so
everything that is in the universe is a
negation of the flat plane flat space
world that uclid had described but he
did start it all so I give him that yeah
okay no because Chuck you remember Chuck
you remember parallel lines never meet
okay right geometry we know they yeah in
in non- uclean Geometry they either meet
or diverge okay they don't just stay the
same distance weird stuff happen it was
a whole other step that everybody had to
take and it was a quite an adjustment I
might add to go there but nonukan job so
we should have call it a nonukan mission
the non- ukian
mission wow
that that get people looking that stuff
up at that point man that's a serious
this right there the non by the way uid
this is not your mission okay just just
letting you know this is the nonukan
mission
okay so Jason this is great it looks
like you're gonna have new knowledge to
surface in the coming months and
definitely years so give us a call when
you got something to report and we would
be delighted to get you back on would
love to find out because I for me it's
the biggest mystery in all of Science
Now is the dark energy problem it really
is very Lexing and so Jason also thank
your three bosses the head of JPL the
head of Caltech and the head of NASA for
Lending you to us yeah you'll do that
for us I will thank you yeah all right
excellent thanks for being on with us
Chuck always good to have you man so
much fun always a pleasure all right
this has been Star Talk our Dark Energy
Edition with a touch of cosmic queries
within and my friend and colleague Jason
rhods from JPL this has been star talk
as always always I bid you to keep
looking
[Applause]
[Music]
up